if you're your average joe you're on a
standard american diet you're getting a
slump in the afternoon maybe you're a
little have some covert weight like what
are some easy things people could change
to improve their lives one of the things
that i've done recently or that i do
regularly that i think really helps me
is i take hiatuses from caffeine i love
caffeine but i find that it definitely
messes me up and it's you know i was in
denial for a long time about it but if i
consume too much i experience that wired
and tired or i feel like i've been hit
by a train later in the afternoon
caffeine is an ergogenic compound so
it's a performance booster it boosts
mental acuity it boosts physical
performance in the gym however i think
when people are dependent on it the
boost that they're getting isn't a boost
from their baseline performance it's
merely treating their withdrawal from
caffeine and so you need to continue to
dose yourself with caffeine to have even
your baseline level of performance so i
think the key is to just not become
dependent on it and to cycle it so
currently i'm i'm off caffeine i'm
sipping some lines i mean